I want to just recap what Jim Jordan
revealed two days ago here's a shorter
version of his Twitter
thread bombshell report on the
censorship industrial complex hundreds
of secret reports show how that the DHS
gov and sisa gov which is cyber security
and infrastructure Security Agency and
the gec which is the state department
Stanford University and others work
together to censor Americans before the
2020 election including true information
jokes and opinions the federal
government disinformation experts
experts over at universities big Tech
and others worked together through
election through the election Integrity
partnership to Monitor and censor
American speech according to one e EIP
member the EIP was created at the
request of sisa the head of the EIP also
said that the EIP was created after
working on some modering ideas with sisa
here's how it worked EIP stakeholders
including the federal government would
submit misinformation reports EIP would
analyze the report and find similar
content across platforms EIP would
submit the report to Big Tech often with
a recommendation on how to censor the
Judiciary GOP and weaponization uh of
that's the weaponization of government
Department obtained these non-public
documents and information from Stanford
only after the threat of contempt uh of
Court who was targeted Americans of all
political Stripes but especially
conservatives and here's just a couple
Donald Trump n Gingrich Mike hucke Shan
Hannity harit Dylan that's PNG g- B- an
that's harit uh Charlie Kirk etc etc and
yes it didn't stop there even went after
Newsmax Ruben report I can't believe it
I like that guy James o'keef uh and uh
he finished up by saying what speech was
targeted for censorship true information
jokes and political
opinions